the last three films you did the fighter
silver linings playbook and American
hustle all won you Academy Award
nominations for directing and a couple
for writing as well and they were all
nominated for Best Picture so with that
kind of thing going on what was the
reason for doing joy what what made you
want to do this picture as your next one
after having that I aspire to create
stories that take on new ambitions and
starting with the fighter women had
become progressively important in each
of the pictures you know with Jennifer
with all the ladies all the sisters and
the fighter and the mother Melissa Leo
to the to Jennifer and silver linings
playbook who was a 20 year old unknown
when we started and virtually and The
Hunger Games has not come out yet and
then American hustle she and Amy Adams
sort of as very interesting characters
and now one were the woman's at the
center of it and there's many different
kinds of women in the in the picture
there including Isabella Rossellini and
they that is fascinating to me but to
make it about the soul of a little girl
from when she's 10 years old and what
made up her psyche and what can happen
to a dream and the cicada metaphor of
being hidden from yourself for 17 years
and what will make you while remaining
loyal and loving and the beauty of that
story and the heartbreak that along the
way was a sizeable thing for me that I'd
never done before that included soap
operas which was part of her mother's
world and part of her psyche and also
included her dreams so it was an
ambitious thing cinematically for me to
do that about the soul of a woman and
the men who were part of her journey
with the other women so a true story
I'm you've taken some different roads on
it but joy Mangano was noted as an
executive producer here so a lot of this
happened and you spent a lot of time
with her right I spent a lot of time on
the phone with her I didn't want to meet
her in person because one of the first
things I said to her the jennifer and i
were brought this project by elisabeth
Gabler and jim gianopolous and we said
we want to do what we want to do with it
which is
with we want to turn it into a fable
that is lifelong so we used some of them
as a much of many of the crazier things
are true the gun range Texas California
the gun of the 900 number with the
girlfriend who banks everything the
unanxious presence in the room the the
mother with the soap operas and the guy
from Detroit who makes it all possible
and the best divorce couple in America
as well as well as you know for me that
in the sibling who is a friend but also
an adversary without these adversaries
and fairytales you can't become what
you're meant to be so the adversaries
are very important joy I had many phone
calls with her she thought I was
psychoanalyzing her it was all those
details it was all those details that
she thought were meaningless that I
seized upon all those wild details like
the gun range and you know what soaps
her mother watched and what her
grandmother was like and how she
supported her and how her husband lived
in the basement and how it happened on a
boat and all this stuff Diane you are
the positive force here you really are
for joy you're you know rooting her on
against all odds there and that's a
great character to play I would think
too the privilege to play and inspire
which we don't see a lot in movies today
guys not only the film but to be the
person to tell her was important for me
to tell her that she could do anything
she put her mind to because to be honest
when I was a little girl growing up my
father was a veterinarian in Mississippi
he was a kind good man that took care of
dogs and cows and hogs and so to be able
to use some of myself because my father
said to me Don as a little girl Diane by
God don't you ever forget child you can
do any damn thing you put your mind to
as long as you stick to it and work hard
and the harder you work the luckier you
are unless it's something that God
doesn't want you to do and if he doesn't
he'll let you know soon enough so you
won't waste your time and I want to do
want to say though for myself as
the narrator I couldn't have done it
that way if it hadn't been for David
because he for me as an actress
the narration part of the film which
originally I was not the narrator this
came later after I'd finished the film
it was a decision that if they brought
me back in and to do the narration
David guided me totally I had to lower
my voice to a low level in a constant
voice and keep the energy in a straight
River flowing and also at the same time
to put my heart and soul into it was one
of the hardest performances I've ever
had to do in my life and I could not
have done it if it wasn't for this
genius director for which I'm very
grateful that's all Bradley it looks
like he's an old-style movie mogul with
this newfangled thing you know on you
know of the Home Shopping Network he
just believes it all and it comes
through in your performance in your eyes
a lot of it too watching this thing and
the way the set goes around and that
must have been something that was fun I
mean it was a privilege to to play a guy
who thought outside the box he comes
from Detroit
he managed Kmart stores and now he's
trying this idea because I got a name
Barry Diller gave him a shot and now he
has the opportunity to give this woman
joy a shot and so to play a character
that is along the way of the her Odyssey
and allows her to then you know fulfill
that that 17 year long cicada you know
package that she hasn't been able to
unearth was that what that was great he
has an odyssey theory tell you're
obviously theory I like you're honest
what about the movie yeah what do you
mean did yeah that she said that you
know she visits all these difference
like The Odyssey really the movie in a
lot of ways cuz she starts out with the
family and then goes on the bullying
goes though she's handed off from Robert
De Niro's metal shop world and the
mother so pop world and her sister she's
handed off to Edgar Ramirez his singing
world based on a true character and from
that world she's handed off to to this
man as well to the Emerald City and and
then from there she has to go make her
bones in California and Dallas you know
while still being true to who she really
is at the end as a tender-hearted person
with some magic in her Wow who knew you
were making an epic that's a it's great
it's great now Virginia
I must say it's very realistic I'm
assuming you don't watch soap operas
that religiously or I still do you do
well there's not very many of them on
any longer but I still watch them
because it's kind of like it it just it
just makes me relax I started watching
them when I was a little girl and I was
especially obsessed with Susan Lucci and
was kind of like a 10 year old when I
met her in the van going to the set and
it was you know they were stars to me
and their acting style reminded me of
silent pictures and they were kind of
bigger than life and I knew that they
worked so hard and had to memorize you
know 30 or 40 pages a day and and and I
started sort of like kind of obsessing
and meeting them and there's several of
them that are became my friends from All
My Children in General Hospital and so
it was it was it was really wonderful to
see them coming on to this movie set
because they're such underappreciated
actors and but the thing is if you're
good on a soap you're probably really
really good and so what a thing it was
for them to be brought into David's
world and and to be on a movie set
finally how much they had all dreamed of
this and then you know still playing
soap opera characters but but David you
didn't make fun of them you know he made
them these bigger than life characters
but here they were in a place where they
could really be appreciated and it was a
great thrill for me to be in the scenes
with them this is unconventional in
movies that I haven't seen the friendly
divorce and he lives in the basement and
and is in business with her and still is
and this is all true in real life to get
to play that that must have been kind of
special for you it was very special I've
been discussing in you know
gatherings it's uh it's it's it's a
dynamic that we that we don't see very
often in films and and I think that when
we fall in love it's you know the the
deepest aspiration is for this love to
last forever and and I think that would
when true love really hits and we have
the resources to make it work
the fact that one aspect of that love
doesn't work doesn't necessarily turn it
into a failure into something that that
we see in this couple and it's very
refreshing it's beautiful it's beautiful
to see that that there a relationship
that an unconditional love a
relationship based on unconditional love
can really take different different
forms and and become and become
fraternal in the way in the way we see
in the film and that is and there is
very beautiful and and I've also where
this class and earlier for me as an
actor to be to be able to play a
character that that I've said to David
I'm very grateful cause it's is one of
the most courageous character of the
most courageous character that I've ever
played because in a society where were
the were the Macho Man date and the and
and the the match his macho normative
society it is very refreshing and very
beautiful and actually pure tie guys to
see to see a character a man that that
we thought any reservation without any
hesitation freely humbly and and without
compromising any ange of his manhood is
willing to to stand by the support and
to celebrate the strength and the
determination and the decisions of the
woman that he loves and and the mother
of his children and that for me was was
was beautiful it was beautiful to play
something like that and being being a
feminist that I am you know and having a
mother and having a sister you know who
were a struggle and have gone through to
their own their own their own personal
struggles it is very beautiful to to to
to see to see a relationship that can
that can turn into that way and and
without making any political statement
about it it's beautiful that in a movie
that is so that is so moving and so
touching you see you see that kind of
you see a guy who's who's willing to
serve the woman she loves and that's the
hill
that was very beautiful for me that's
great
now Elisabeth Rohm you know we all know
people like Peggy and I actually had a
epithelia and she's feeling it and she's
almost you know you almost felt like she
was cheering for her to fail and that's
that's got to be kind of tough to play
actually in some ways yeah I think um
you know I personally relate to that
person in the family dynamic that's you
know I I am a stepchild you know and I
relate to that sort of that in that role
you know a feeling like there's the
there's the other child that's a
priority or and at the same time you
know she I feel like you know what we
really experiencing joy go through is is
overcoming the obstacles to her innate
magic you know and and every one of us
has that person or multiple people who
just say you can't do this you're not
good enough to do this or you know or
discreetly or obviously or jealous or
want to stand in our way so we all have
those people we have to overcome and so
to play Peggy I understand the hurt that
she would feel but I also understand how
each of us have to overcome those people
our family dynamics you know and also in
our work dynamics in our life dynamics
you know you also said what I just heard
you say today which was I'd never heard
you say which is that it came naturally
because Jennifer yeah yeah I think also
there you know having done to movies
with Jennifer I mean I feel so
vulnerable with her and automatically
just have felt this you know bond with
her but it takes a lot of vulnerability
I think to play a sister relationship
and and both she and I you know have
this ability to connect but Jennifer she
has so much grace and so much magnitude
and so much beauty and ease you know
there's this effortlessness with her and
so Peggy myself I can look at Jennifer
and and Peggy looks at joy and thinks
you know just this this envy you know of
what she doesn't have and so I think you
can truly you can
Jennifer and I having known each other
now for many years like David and I but
you know being able to access that
together I think is a sister
relationship we all can relate to
congratulations to all of you
congratulations on joy Dave thank you
Pete thank you